[Musique]
il y a une nouvelle qui intègre les
missions à elle et sur ses stars à elle
s'appelle jesse elle est originaire du
sud
elle a fait ses études à nice la nature
et la beauté sont ses passions elle a
été mannequin mais toujours elle est aux
côtés de jimmy buzz sur ses stars oui
oui et oui
demel et les chéris elle va intégrer
l'émission or je vous dis tout de suite
je vous dit tout je crois que tous les
garçons l'ont vu qu'est ce qu'on pouvait
dire sur elle elle est splendide
c'est tout bon fraîche bénéfique très
belle très intelligente a à l'époque où
les chéris va partir du principe que
vous êtes tous célibataires
je vais faire entrer jesse et vous allez
avoir 30 entre 30 secondes et une minute
pour la séduire
d'accord je ne suis pas là faites ce que
vous voulez et les choix de vie c'est
elle qui choisira lequel est celui qui a
été le plus convaincant
d'accord je voulais que je fasse rentrer
dieu si le crabe et chérie c'est jessy
qui nous rejoint applaudissements
produits
[Applaudissements]
des fruits les cherry est ce que vous
pouvez libérer bien sûr canada corp
attention j'ai si ma chérie merci d'être
avec nous tout cas c'est ta première
aujourd'hui
jessy qui est magnifique et est très
sympathique 28 mois tu vas venir avec
moi non mais tu veux pas venir là alors
on va envoyer le premier séducteur et le
premier séducteur c'est gilles verdez à
l'exil
mais si la santé de la pac mac sur le
toit attention ou discuter comme ça on
va apprendre plus de chaussures jesse
attention ces paroles alghisi c'est chez
vous des hashtags le hashtag avec le
meilleur c'est du seuil de minutes
dominées suite en fin d'hiver 2010 avec
le hashtag est la personne qui a été
pour vous le meilleur séducteur c'est
parti six lancements agile ou un cas des
jeux d'enfants comme moi mal et même jeu
d'enfant le même regard à maille sur le
monde
il ya beaucoup de four bisimwa mais moi
je suis là sincérité je suis tu sentais
pas bien non les chiffres et si vous
voulez remettre un petit cadran lama
comme ça on voit le voulez vous mettre
la barre haute tarentaise
laissez moi c'était de voir s'il vous
plaît la cij organise également cette
émission à bercy
attention c'est parti on va envoyer
maintenant benjamin castel event chalet
soit bon mois nous a habitués
allez on y va et on va en apprendre un
peu plus sur du site bon j'ai si c'est
vrai que on se connaît déjà
oui que tu as fortement oui que tu as eu
la chance de garder un plein petit
garçon capricieux peut-être oui qui
monfils exactement au final tu étais sa
nounou mais j'étais baby sitter which is
de kamal rien jeter pu décoller de
divorcer
c'était un à lui était aux états unis
donc je n'ai pas croisé croisés et voilà
la suite après que j'étais les vestaires
de son fils déjà choisi / photo subito
je connais déjà la famille voilà déjà on
a déjà fait un pas en avant un bout de
chemin en france des prix bas est bon
c'est vrai que je suis accro
connaisseurs dans tout ce qui est
mariage divorce planner au moins deux
pannes leur organisation je sois au
choix de la robe
oui il a déjà peu 3,3 déjà je pourrais
c'est la même jesse quels sont tes
passions dans la vie tu si j'en ai
tellement oui ouais la première je pense
que c'est l'être humain
l'être humain me passionne de red hat en
main ouais alors jessica l'être humain
par nbc qui te passionne tous a priori
franchement qui me passionne nos kits
ats opus qui es tu content intrigue et
intrigue le plus c'est peut-être gilles
verdez ou pansements psychologiquement
ça joue entre jean michel et je
regardais ce pensent aussi mal un suivi
psychologique va être intéressés
d'accord c'est vrai alors vers les
images quel est ton type d'homme belle
journée je me laisse un peu aller
suivant mon feeling les énergies
un contrôle et décolorée c'est pas mal
c'est pas banal et l'ins merci bravo
on va maintenant il en perdra j'irai au
boss qu'on va demander à maxime galy à
tsingoni abidjan n'a eu à faire bien
attention ils nagent première un moyen
d'aller chez vous qui nous regardent et
va draguer jesse ne dira après elle nous
dira après elle me dit à chaque fois
celui qu'elle élimine tout de suite elle
en gardera un poème que tu t'appelles gc
ca avec i way s'est longtemps que l'on
table comme ça et j'ai toujours depuis
ma naissance et à ce que c'est sur nous
on a dit c'est moi la province en
attendant les pelles coupe du monde
robertet ce candidat il nous manque
comme si vous êtes avec une meuf qui
t'appelle défini ça fait longtemps que
tu peux faire un échange connard mais
revoilà déjà très bien tout ça pouvait
être un surnom peut-être de seine
enfin j'ai été conçus aux états unis
donc je pense qu'elle a une influence
l'afro-américaine alors ouais mais je
suis né à cannes mais non mais tu peux
pas faire ça fait quand même le échange
verbal les jeux de langue c'est toujours
quelque chose
4 le jeu de l'ange chez les gens a pas
aller il te reste dix secondes et je
crois qu'on a un point commun tu aimes
les spiritualités oui c'est ça donc tu
fonctionner l'énergie exacte cela dure
sans les gens et bossa et le tursan
l'équipe a énormément ouais ouais c'est
bien d'être avec lui aussi m'a
évidemment ça m'énerve est très content
de te voir
merci tout le plaisir qu'il a eu en tout
cas merci beaucoup c'est toi c'est bon
il est pas il a été mauvais alors il ya
le producteur d'émissions qui me dit il
n'a pas été mauvais attention
apparemment il n'a pas vu la même
séquence connu
allez il reste deux séducteurs et l'a
pas dit moi je pense jean louis way le
prêt par jean luc est ce que tu es prêt
allez on y va jean-luc à la normalement
on note grave et après on terminera bien
entendu par la catastrophe industrielle
alors alors je suis déjà je vais je vais
essayer de pas faire un entretien
d'embauché comme maxime berger si j'ai
pas envie de jouer de la flûte comme
tous les autres mais ça fait quoi ça
fait six ans six ans que fait l'émission
oui et je crois que la première fois que
je comprends pourquoi je suis là à ses
passages à donner un sens un petit peu
caché que jouer de la flûte à l'élection
et en plus depuis que je sais que tu
étais baby sitter je me sens donné
garçons soleil se hisse budget
[Rires]
voilà donc je sais je sais pas ce que tu
comptes faire mais si tu voulais revivre
ce que tu as vécu avec enzo mais
j'aimerais bien que tu me protège
d'abord et après je pense que je te
protège très bien
[Applaudissements]
ces annonces ont maintenant vous nous
rejoignez on a une nouvelle dans
l'équipe s'appelle jessy qui est très
sympa et qui tous les to les chroniques
mais voilà les deux mois ça tu est
dégueulasse allez vas-y basses et hautes
études et vous êtes vous jamais tu
laisses études et goût de tout le monde
la fin de l'année de la pub oui j'essaie
je vais pas te mentir le physique est
très important pour moi et franchement
tu es sublime tu as des yeux un visage
voilà qui est expert expressif et puis
retenterait 106 m mais c'est vrai que
j'y attache beaucoup d'importance et
rien que pour ça déjà jorion rittaud
draguer mais rien qu'en discutant un peu
avec toi j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
au-delà de l'image voilà une sensibilité
à logis aussi mais personne ne le
découvre chez moi parce que je pense
qu'il souffre aussi de ta beauté et moi
je souffre de mon personnage
si toi tu as envie de voir ce qu'il ya
derrière l'image un peu dégueulasse en
mieux et loire l'homme est ce que tu as
envie de construire moi j'ai franchement
je vais me poser je te propose pas te
poser toutes ces pc tu veux qu'on
discute avec fribourg c'est très
important
voilà qu'on se marre on passe des bons
moments enfin pique nique n'importe quoi
et moi en tout cas je ne promets que si
peu d'intérêt pour moi je regarderai
qu'aucune fille gens veulent plus que
toi je n'attendais pas franchement pas
mal oui et non
alors venez là il ou s'ils perdaient
s'il a disparu à l'image vient du verbe
pression j'ai attention geci déjà tu vas
devoir en éliminer un direct qui est une
mission premier vous pourrez vous pouvez
retourner là bas alain moussy rex et
comparatifs dans cet objectif pour moi
le l'avant après l' île désolée mais ça
m'a pas non j'ai pas été
éliminés oui oui oui les soldes tuent
tant redouté est ce que vous éliminez
maintenant au dossier en 13e à benjamin
benjamin pour quel motif propreté mariée
à un basset séducteur et puis là il m'a
pas beaucoup posé question n'était pas
dans un échange il y en a plus pas voilà
je sais pas j'aime ma femme merci j'ai
progressé dans le lac albert en plus à
meylan lacroix style vraiment trois
styles pour enfin moi j'ai été convaincu
par jean-luc 1 ça a été le haut niveau
de deux phrases je suis très sensible à
la littérature française et donc quand
on s'exprime et voit la balle à côté du
ramadam il est mort alors qu'elle touche
on voit la pince un ballet web bah oui
c'est moi éliminé maxime est machine du
ponant plateau tu as quelque chose à
dire je te remercie je dis non merci
alors et maintenant ça se joue entre
jean luc et jean michel est franchement
c'est je rappelle tant que joueur c'est
une seule célibataire d2 mais non mais
c'est tout vu non mais c'est tout fait
pour moi parce qu'il ya hors de question
que ce soit jean michel noble cet accord
nous préfèrent la marque et jean-luc
allemand qui lui n'est ce pas une chance
pourquoi eux et j'y crois pas non non ça
s'embrasse ange prenne garde jean-michel
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire à qui si
bas qu'elle peut mais je respecte son
choix mais qu'elle fait une grosse
connerie
qu'est ce que tu entends pas que peu que
c'est pas nous c'est dommage de pas
prendre le seul qui est célibataire
pendant le mariage ou le masque de type
ak vraiment c'est oui des talibans
mais voilà et quand tu me dis je te
promets je regarderai une autre je
regarderai plus aucune autre dans
l'unique roi paris jesse est ce que j'ai
un choix définitif
non mais dans ce cas c'est vraiment
l'équipe dans l'udc et 10 i/s qui est ce
qu'on à giovanni en ligne
la durée ni giovanni est ce que tu es là
giovanni ah oui c'est un bon ba ba
attend ça va et toi mon chéri tu as qu
est ce qu un super qu'est ce que tu
attends signal est-ce que tu apprécies
la nouvelle jesse oui oui des rebelles
est allée elle est très intelligente et
très sympathique mercedi voulons pas
faire sa première émission d'un instant
est ce que tu es content de ce couple
jesse jean-luc bien sûr pour l'instant
c'est un couple d'amis ti d'amitié puis
jean-luc mais vraiment un fait du tort
de folie et jovani en fait j'avais un
jeu clair faire mais comme on a pu le
temps je t'offre tout de suite un
smartphone c'est pourquoi ces cadeaux à
l'approché et je compte et je rajoute la
corbeille de fruits entamé très voilà
d'accord c'est pour nous c'est cadeau
jean luc et désirs j'arrive aussi le
banc d'où la notion alesi partait tous
les deux parties tout est d'être ici
voilà la la la la
ça irait si vite pour moi la wii mais ça
va quand même ils sont très beaux les 2
1 et sur ma vie je fais une passe
décisive frères une passe les fait
rigoler un frère mais non une passe
décisive à une levée une passe décisive
comme ça il me dit rien oui je sais je
sais que je n'aurais pas dû le mettre en
salopette et excusez moi est ce que tu
peux aller vérifier les niveaux on se
retrouve sur le plateau les cherry on se
retrouve de tweed savez vous